show me that
get on the ground get on the ground dude
look away look away
look away from me turn your head to the
right
don't move don't move okay yes sir
I'm here I don't win any problems
I don't want any problems huh
yes sir
[Music]
I don't want any problems
I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry
what do you mean
a lot of work for nothing what do you
mean
no sir okay no
lots of bullets I don't have bullets
I don't know I didn't do anything you
got anything that's gonna poke me stick
me no sir no sir
[Music]
what did I do
what I do
I'm sorry what did I do
I'm sorry
I do
just clear that car
I don't want any problems
what do you mean a lot of work for
nothing what do you mean
Vehicles clear no sir okay